哈囉 大家好歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
今天我們邀請到的
大來賓是丁寧丁姐
哈囉大家好我是丁寧
我今天
看到丁姐的第一句話是
欸丁姐你跟電視上
看起來一模一樣耶
我超開心的因為大部分人都會
說啊 那個你本人比較好看耶啊
對本人也很好看
但是我的意思是就是就是像
走出來一樣
沒有電視會看起來會比較不同嘛
但是我就很高興聽到這種一致的
感覺對真的很一致 那丁姐
整個狀態非常非常好然後
最近丁姐出了新書就是
丁寧的轉念學 那因為
這個轉念
對於我們其實日常生活
有很多東西很有關係
然後包含我自己最近推一課
叫停止內耗裡面
有講到很多很類似轉念的一些東西
所以我就想說
這簡直就是一個上天的
旨意 就是我一個朋友講說
這是我給這個世界的禮物
我剛開始就覺得不好意思我怎麼
可以說給世界的禮物不好意思
可是我之後仔細想一想
對啊因為我的確是學習
無論是常常課程或是
身心靈課程真的是我覺得我在
這二十年來我都不斷的在幫我學到的
這些東西在我生活裡面實驗
是因為我覺得任何東西如果你沒有
幫助到你的生活或是讓
你的生命更放鬆或是
更有彈性我覺得這都是空口白話
嗯對 所以我練習了二十年
當我有一天突然發現我長成這個
樣子的時候我突然覺得說
哇原來我學的這些東西
都這麼有用啊那如果這樣子的話
我是不是應該要把這樣子的
途徑把它簡化然後用
更簡單的方式來練習讓
大家可以應用在生活當中
對不對 因為我一直覺得說就是跟
運動一樣 因為我是一個很愛
運動的人 我覺得我都不斷
的在內在跟外在裡面
做跳來跳去的學習
我發現其實你內在的想法
它是可以透過不斷
的一些小小練習的
累積當有時候發生一件
很重要的事情的時候你就突然
會做出一個跟你以前不一樣
的反應那
那個反應就會救了你
而且那個反應會改變你的人生
丁姐在說的這個東西跟我們
心理學在講的就是我們
會有一套我們自己習慣的
思考模式就是我們的SOP
對對 就是丁姐在書裡面
講的SOP那我們在一般
心理學會有很多很複雜的詞
比如說什麼什麼統覺架構 或是什麼
神經迴路 或是
內在運作模式等等其實簡單的說
那就是我們遇到事情的一套的確就是SOP
我們會怎麼反應我們怎麼感受我們
怎麼思考然後我們會怎麼反應
那這一件事情呢其實比我們
想像中的還要固化
對 還要複雜對 沒錯那
可是這一切都是我們養下來的
有點像是我們遇到東西
緊急的狀況的時候就是有東西
掉下來
如果我是右撇子我就會用右手去接它就是
一個自動化反應
但話說回來剛剛丁姐講到一個
很重要的事情是當我們今天
想要調整我們的這個習慣
或者是說我們想要培養
第二專長就是這原本是
我們的第一專長
現在我們要培養新的SOP流程那
就是必須要在
每一次反射動作遇到這件事情很
就是自動化的時候要先有
辦法讓自己停一下因為能夠
停一下前額葉
才可以動作它才可以
因為這是大腦的習慣就是你如果用
你之前的迴路如果這跟
你的創傷因為大部分壓力
事件都跟創傷有關
對它就會走你的
大腦邊緣系統啊那些就是比較
哺乳類跟爬蟲類就
自動化的那個部分可是只要
你有辦法去覺察跟意識
前額葉理性的這個部分
它會開始可以運動它
它可以動 它可以運作
然後它運作之後 就等於是
每一次你要遇到這個事情的時候
前額葉就會欸 上次我們
有運作過喔我們有選擇過喔
所以它就不會馬上走那個這其實就跟那個
快思慢想的系統一
系統二很像就是
它就不會馬上走那個舊系統
它會新系統會欸 等一下
這個東西我熟等一下 我看一下 我
看一下對對對那就會停下來那就
差很多了對 那個就是轉
變那就是我們在身心靈
自己常常講的覺察
心理學是說前額葉的
迴路會開始啟動
但是身心靈是講的是覺察
其實我們在諮商也會用
覺察因為像我剛剛講的其實
比較偏向腦科學的東西
我好愛聽喔 但是那也
不算是我的專業那只是
因為之前我對情緒有興趣
做了一些研究可是在
我們諮商的確最常說
的都是覺察對
可是覺察
這件事情聽起來對於有些人
沒有做過這件事情就會想
說什麼叫做
覺察就是改變的開始
因為我在你書有看到這句話這句話跟我
自己很喜歡的完形心理學
講的話是一樣的
完形心理學也是認為你覺察
就是改變的開始
可是這件事情其實很多人很難懂
我在我書的前面就講說
你要先相信姑且給這一個
作者一個機會就是他講的
都是對的
你不要他講一句你心裡面講說放屁
在講什麼鬼
對你來講這件事就完全
你沒有機會所以就是說你要先姑且
先相信好ㄩ你先相信這兩個字
就把這兩個字先放在心上
什麼叫覺察
我不太懂但是應該有這麼一件事情
我為什麼叫三十個日常
練習我設計的三十 個非常簡單
你在日常上一定會遇到的事情
從淺到深慢慢的練習
我覺得覺察的培養跟運動能力
也是一樣的我剛才講的
那淺而夜這件事情例如
說你每天早上起來你就一定會去7-11
買一杯拿鐵
這是你固定模式
我現在就是這樣子固定
你基本上你走去7 -11 你都不用點人家
就是欸拿鐵是嗎喔今天
要冰還是熱的 但是呢
你只要一天ok 我本來
就點拿鐵我今天就喝
黑咖啡你會不會覺得今天
暫停了暫停那一剎
那就開始像老師你講的
開始啟動你的前額葉聽
你說什麼今天就要點不一樣
的東西 那我就點黑咖啡
所以我的前額葉就多了
一點點欸 我有黑咖啡的選項
那這些東西都是小事情
例如說我去點pasta
餐廳都說你可不可以
點別的 我們還有別的東西
很好吃 因為我就是巨蟹座
非常的固執 我就覺得紅醬好
我就覺得就是我不想去踩雷
不想要怎樣我不想去冒險
這是我以前性格的一部分
所以從那時候開始我開始
改變我就一直點別的
白醬青醬亂點反正就是
不要點跟我自己原本點的
一樣我的前額葉又開始
多了一點點的方向
多一個選項其實 當你不斷
不斷這樣培養你在每個
幾秒鐘的選項的時候 其實
你在培養自己覺察能力
因為你已經在看自己在
幹嘛其實覺察就是看著自己
在做什麼你只要每天
就這樣子幾秒鐘幾分鐘
就像你每天去練
那個push up
第一次練一下喔很累
第二次欸兩下 你會越來越能夠
增加你身體的肌力
覺察這個能力跟你訓練
身體的肌力是一樣的
當你不斷就做這些練習30天就乖乖的做
喔都是簡單的然後今天說ok
例如說今天靜坐5分鐘
啊不會靜坐沒關係
就坐在那邊就好了 就這樣它就會
慢慢累積到一個狀態
開始會發現你對很多東西開始
改變因為你開始會想了
你開始不會順著你習慣
的神經迴路就往前
你就會開始思考停頓
你一停頓你所有該啟
動的東西就哇就開啟
了沒有錯欸
其實剛就是丁姐在講的東西是覺察
的幾個很重要的步驟
第一個步驟就是你要看得見
所以你知道那知道的時候呢我們
有時候需要就是好奇好奇
這件事情所以覺察這件事情
它的確有一些層次就比如說
像丁姐說的喔
我知道我平常都這樣做
那我試著挑戰看看做一點別的
所以我有意識到這件事
所以這就是一個有意識的選擇對
那另外也有一個 覺察很好用的地方我自己
很常用就比如說像剛剛
丁姐說的
我看了一個書就有心裡想說天啊
你在講什麼不想相信這個東西
看見這個狀態欸我不想
相信這個書然後
多好奇一件事情就是
為什麼我會這樣
為什麼我對這個東西這麼有反感
或是我不喜歡或是我排斥
為什麼呢所以沒有對錯沒有好壞
只是知道
為什麼也是一種看見那是一個暫停
對
我非常喜歡你這個說法因為我也
會做這樣子的練習然後我想
說欸對
我為什麼會對這件事情有這麼大的反應
我就開始 想說我自己有什麼東西跟
某些事情連結然後
最後又發展出另外一個感覺就是
我相信我相信我們是跟這個
宇宙共存的我
相信整個宇宙的能量
我相信我們只是宇宙裡面一個
非常小小的東西 但是我們跟整個
宇宙是連結在一起的
就像我常講一沙一世界
所以我相信不會有一件
莫名其妙的事情來到我的眼前
所有來到我眼前的事情
它都是一個機會可以幫助我
更看到別的東西或者是 另外
一方面的成長
因為我培養出一段時間之後我開始
發現我很能夠接收宇宙的訊息
就是
我看到什麼就 欸喔
這應該是一個新的學習
所以因為這個樣子
我世界再也沒有我討厭的東西了
因為所有我討厭的東西我都開始想說都
不是別人的問題 這是我的問題
那我想一下我為什麼對這件事有反應
所以當你不斷這樣用這樣子的角度去
看你發生的事情的時候
整個心情跟壓力都
不一樣像我小孩皮的要命
我跟你講我小孩真的是
但是 我每次發很脾氣的時候
我就跟我自己講說
小孩子絕對沒有問題有問題是我
你不需要叫他們調整
你需要調整是你自己對他們的態度
雖然說你講的話好像
都對但是你自己的態度
呢你是不是有些期待推著你講這些話
有可能有一些聽眾還沒有練到丁姐
這個層級的時候
聽到說什麼有問題都是我
那不是別人那個人對我這樣
他沒有問題嗎 大家的反應可能會
開始覺得說
現在想把他關掉欸
沒也很正常對 我補充一下因為
丁姐這個等級很高
我就是這個俗人先來補充
這有一個非常重要的關鍵
丁姐在強調的東西
其實是我們需要去留意這些
事情對我們產生的影響
我們是怎麼去反應的我們
是怎麼感受的我們是怎麼
思考的最困難的地方
是與其說不用把注意力
放在別人身上都是我的問題
倒不如說它有一個
更重要的關鍵是別人
其實很難改變我們要把
力氣放在別人的改變上我們會很挫折
對 很受傷
然後無力感很強對 可是
一旦我發現我有選擇
可以用我自己的反應去
決定我跟他之間的
關係的變化對我要用什麼
樣子的態度沒錯沒錯這個
東西會讓我慢慢的
不管是長出心理韌性也好
或是讓我慢慢感覺到控制感
讓我感覺到我慢慢
有選擇我可以應對
這件事情其實非常非常重要的
其實丁姐在說的是這個
其實兩個人在對峙的時候就是
例如在 一段關係對峙所以
其實兩個人的能量都是等同大的
都非常大的對
所以才會拉扯嘛
但是能量就是這樣
就像兩個氣球就是如果說
我們都在這個空間裡面但
如果說只要我改變我的能量的狀態
例如說
我讓我的能量稍微比較
鬆軟一點 對方的狀態
一定會跟著調整
因為能量就像水一樣在流動
對 所以我們如果這是真的在
我身上實驗出來的就是我
跟我先生的練習因為關係就是
一面鏡子嘛 所以我
真的發現說我真的改變不了他
我們都是必須經歷過
很多的錯誤之後我們才可以
找到對的方法
我就發現說我這麼用力然後
講這麼多道理為什麼你還
聽不懂我怎麼會這麼的
固化你的頭腦 但是我最後
發現說那這麼困難我來
調整我自己好了 所以當我就
不斷調整我自己我發現
就算我不說什麼就算
我不再唸他或是
不再要求他改變什麼
他自己就變了我覺得這是很奇妙的
會讓你很開心的感覺 沒錯
丁姐你現在在講一個非常
神奇的化學變化我覺得
現在的聽眾朋友一定超想
知道這件事情是怎麼發生因為
這跟丁姐這一次帶來的轉念有關
所以丁姐 可不可以舉個例子
太多例子了 我舉一個
我最常舉的例子我是
36歲那一年開始接觸
身心靈課程跟成長
課程然後我是那一年開始
做諮商然後那時候是因為
感情的狀態太痛苦
但是我想要活下來因為
那時候我真的覺得
我可能很不小心我會幹嘛
我有感覺到因為 我是一個情緒很大的人對
然後那時候我就覺得我要活下來
而且我還有一件事是
我要工作我必須養活我自己
還好我覺得那時候我夠窮
我真的要工作我才能夠
讓我自己生活好好的運作
但是我不能夠用這樣的狀態
去工作 那是沒有用的
人家不會要我的那時候運氣
也非常好就是我認識一個
諮商師也是朋友介紹的
我跟他諮商了快要
到一年的時間然後我發現說
天啊其實我的感情沒有什麼
問題 有問題的都是我跟我的
家人我從小到大我
跟父母親的關係然後包括
我爺爺因為我從小被我爺爺家暴
被家暴長大的小孩這些東西其實我
都覺得說我們長大的這些東西
沒了沒有現在都卡在你的
身體裡面就像我們剛才
老師你講的那種固定
的迴路就在那邊所以
當我遇到那種某些
男性跟我爺爺狀態有點
像說立刻連結他會
打我 那時候我的連結
就是不斷在連結我的家人
連結我爺爺
連結我爸爸 連結我媽媽的
態度我整個人生其實在
36之前都是
我家人的綜合體那真的很不容易
我都一直在反射他們帶給我的
創傷是我都沒有諮商
到感情的老師也是說對
我也覺得你可以的
你不用再花這個錢了
你可以的然後那一段時間
我就覺得說好
我大概 知道我的方向我就開始上身心靈的課程
上身心靈的課程然後之後遇到
我先生我跟他
那六個月的時候我就懷孕三個月
所以我們非常快速地變成一個家庭
所以那時候我就跟我先生講就說
因為我們非常 快速變成一個家庭
所以 我們不要再假來假去了
我們不是在Dating所以你也不用假
我也不用假我們有任何問題
我們就讓他攤出來處理
那你也知道因為我先生
也不是一個脾氣非常好的人
所以有一段時間我們吵到
那種我覺得說天啊怎麼會這樣子
怎麼會是我最不喜歡的狀態的人的綜合體
就在 我先生身上怎麼樣子例
如說我先生非常固執
因為 他在美國當過海軍
你知道 軍人很恐怖因為
他有 真的去打過仗所以他有
他的創傷他太多複雜
的事情 然後
他又是一個大混血
所以從小就被白人
這樣打大的所以他要很
努力讓自己生存一下
所以他非常Tough
所以他非常容易緊繃緊張例如說他在
之前小孩子出門他一定要手
牽著小孩子我就說你幹嘛
這樣子我就小這麼大讓他自己
走路吧他說不行太危險
我說危險什麼然後
他連結 到他過去在洛杉磯的
狀態
因為洛杉磯真的很恐怖
我說我就一直跟他講說
我們現在在臺灣 我們非常安全
所以
你不要帶著你過去的鬼魂
來跟我們一起生活這樣子我們
也會很痛苦然後那時候
就吵吵吵這個狀態我
那時候真的好想把離婚
這兩個字丟出來因為真的覺得
我們沒路走所以看起來很
像是說他這麼做的時候你
會跟他說在臺灣 不用這樣但
他會生氣他可能會想
防衛對
他會覺得我太壞了 然後我的確那時候
我也很不會溝通我都用
指責的方法那我就覺得
說我跟他
真的是沒有辦法溝通
所以那時候我快要把
那個離婚這兩個字丟出來
的時候我突然想到一句
我在上課的時候我們老師講過一句話
即便那時候
我還沒有結婚
他說關係就是一面鏡什麼意思呢
鏡 不會照出你沒有的東西
那時候最氣的就是我現在
太容易憤怒瞭然後
我常常會指責他說是因為他的
憤怒把我的憤怒帶起來
讓我很憤怒
我憤怒高度是非常高然後我就跑到
浴室去然後先大哭然後
就那時候想我想砸東西
你就 身體有一個反應
我要砸 東西 我要破壞東西
但是我絕對不會砸我的手機
我手機太貴瞭然後這樣
我突然看到有一個洗衣板
那你看我那時候還有一點意識
我趕快開水 讓我自己哭也不要那麼
大聲然後就開始拿洗衣板
就猛砸那個浴缸因為
有水我覺得應該會好一點真的
好氣對就是我你看我的情緒的憤怒
有這麼大然後
之後我想到那句話的時候
才發現說其實不是我先生把
他的憤怒帶給我
是我本來就有這個憤怒只是說
因為我可能去壓抑他因為
我覺得憤怒是不好的因為會
連結到我跟我爺爺的
狀態想到我爺爺那個
狀態所以我就是我此生
一直在壓抑我的憤怒
看起來跟他講話好像非常
平靜但是其實我內在是
非常憤怒的但這個東西一直
被我強制的壓抑下來
所以當我先生做這件事情的時候
我就覺得他這個能量就把
我這個能量帶上了所以
那時候我才發現 哇哦這
不是我先生練習
這是我的練習 他是來幫我的要能夠
改成這樣的想法真的很不容易
因為我想大部分的人還是會覺得
說那你不要那麼
我也可以調整 但是你也不要那麼大
但是 你馬上就可以變成因為
前面有這麼長時間的練習就是
我一直講說我從
36歲開始我就這樣
我就是很積極的上好多身心靈課程
那很多課程然後
在不同老師裡面我都有學到
一些東西然後那些東西在那個
時候都覺得應該沒有什麼用吧
我看起來也不會結婚但是
我就覺得反正就學著所以
我就覺得說你有些想法有
時候在 你看翻這本書的時候
你可能不會覺得說這句話
好了不起或是
有什麼大不了的
但是有時候因為它可是
已經在你的整個腦子裡面
但有一天你就突然在
一個緊急抓這句話就
跳出來了就像我那天
那個情況所以那時候你覺得
變成這應該是我的練習你
後來就做了些什麼我就
跟我先生講說那時候因為我是
一個強迫我自己 我自己是
練習出來的以前很多事我是
不會講巨蟹座很悶就是
自己心裡的內心的小劇場
一直在那邊run然後
我就跟我先生講說我之後就
跟他分享這件事情我就我都
會強迫我自己跟他講
很多我上課完之後的感覺
我管他聽得懂聽不懂反正我就是會講對
就可以讓他知道說你
花這個錢沒白花好不好
我是不是帶一些東西回來跟你分享
然後
我就跟他講說我覺得這是我的
練習 他說那我該怎麼辦我說
你不用該怎麼辦你就做你的事
我說什麼我說你就做你的你不用
做任何改變他說那你
那我如果又生氣我就說
那你就生氣啊 他說那你呢
我說我就會我會照顧我自己
那我現在也聽不懂 他真的聽不懂
但是我也沒辦法解釋
因為我也還在
練習 我怎麼有辦法告訴你是
什麼鬼啊我 也不知道啊還好
那時候我們吵架真的夠多
我有很多的練習他吵架
的時候我就想到我們老師提醒
的把注意力放在自己身上
感受這件事情帶給你的
感覺然後就覺得非常有趣
有時候同樣的吵一件事情
這次吵架我會覺得說怎麼樣
你是瞧不起我們臺灣人是不是
你覺得你美國人是比較優越
是不是然後有時候會覺得說
你是不是不愛我你才會
講這樣子的話然後有時候會覺得
說這是我的錯嗎 真的是我的問題嗎
就是我發現好有趣就是
每一次基本上如果吵一樣的
事情 但是我會有很多不同的
想法 我們也不可能 我一直
能夠維持這樣子看著自己
的感覺因為我們
還是要跟對方吵嘛 有時候我可能
只能夠hold個一分鐘我的
天啊他是不是瞧不起我啊
其實這瞧不起他又連結
到我小時候我家裡面破產的事情
你知道我有多少事情可以
連結然後一下子可以一分鐘
又被他拉住哎呀又下去
嚯一下就吵了所以這
每次的吵每次的吵
我覺得那個停留在自己身上
時間越來越長了你
越來越能夠感覺到自己
我現在覺得說他不愛我
但是他真的是不愛我嗎
只是有沒有可能他的憤怒是
他的問題不是我的問題 所以他的憤怒
跟我是沒有關係的也跟
他愛不愛我沒有關係就是
我們像一個聚光燈好了我
開始把這個聚光燈調到
我自己身上的時間長了
一分鐘兩分鐘三分鐘有一次
我們又在車上大吵然後
那一天我就有一種很特別
的感覺那時候
我只有一個小孩 我女兒坐在車上
我現在是一個在小孩子面前
很控制自己不要罵髒話的人
然後那一天我就
開車然後又不知道什麼時候開始
然後我突然有一種感覺
因為在吵的過程中
雖然我嘴巴也這樣回但是
我心裡面有一種安靜然後
我突然有一種很清楚的
感覺是我知道我講哪一句
話他可以立刻calm下來
非常的清楚這句話一定有用
但是我也非常清楚我講什麼話
會讓他整個抓狂
突然覺得說來試試看
他會怎麼樣我就講了那句
果然大爆罵髒話
因為我一直罵出來然後啪啪
然後我就這樣開車
我就發現很有趣的是他在那邊狂飆
然後我開車然後我一直感覺
我心像一個平靜的火
我不是假的是 因為我一直
在看著我就覺得好有趣
我心裡好平靜
他在飆的時候 我不要助燃
他自己 燒完就下來了對不對
就是我 沒有丟助燃劑他就啪
啪啪自己啪啪啪之後他
就突然到一個點的時候他
突然他覺得好像嚇到他
自己他突然就他說很抱歉
我說我很抱歉然後女兒
就大哭了
他就跟女兒道歉I'm sorry
然後他就跟我說我怎麼會這樣子我說
他就講說我不會再這樣子
很抱歉我怎麼會這個樣子
我怎麼會說這樣子的話
就很平靜我就又轉頭
跟他講說你不要跟我道歉
我覺得我才應該要謝謝你
他就嚇到他說在講什麼
我說我要謝謝你治療我
對憤怒的恐懼所以其實
丁姐你剛剛在講的這個
東西 我覺得在有些朋友聽到
這個經驗的時候可能會覺得很特別
因為某方面會覺得說你就
知道講什麼話他會跑起來
為什麼你還要講那句話
你不選那個會讓他冷靜的話
可是我覺得丁姐剛剛講
到一個很大的重點是因為
這件事情跟你個人的一些議題
有關對然後對你來說有
一點像是我在測試一個東西
那就是我以前總是覺得
別人只要我讓他憤怒
他就會傷害我對會不會
這個人不一樣會不會這個人
不會這麼做他可能會很憤怒
但是我可能承受得住
OK 我中間夾一個小故事
有一次我們是吵架
吵吵吵吵一個狀態然後
因為我真的覺得我可能真的是已經
開始在練習覺察我自己
這些東西已經在我身體裡面
因為那時候我們才剛結婚一年吧
我心裡想
因為他已經造一個我覺得他
已經快要抓狂了
但是我就覺得說
我必須要先確定他會不會打我
因為他如果會打我就不用講了
別說了 我覺得一出手
就什麼事都不用說對
我絕對不會給他機會的
所以 我覺得說與其怕後面
浪費時間倒不如
現在把他解決這是一個非常好的時機
那你現在要打我嗎
你這麼生氣 你看起來我會覺得
你好像要打我了
那我先聽到這句話
他立刻就有擋一下
他說我絕對不會打你OK 那我就OK
就是我要確定這件事情如果
在他心裡面有一個界線
絕對不出手這件事情
對他來講是一件非常重要
的事情
那我就可以跟你耗一輩子了
說實在話我在
聽丁姐講這個東西的時候
有一些想法跟習慣跟我們
就是諮商的一些習慣很像
但的確有一些想法
對我們來說是有危險的
對 有危險的我可以理解
因為比如說因為我們通常
會鼓勵就是在那個情況讓
情緒下降越好但是剛剛
丁姐講到一個很重要的
一個部分是在於說就是
對方今天情緒他上來
的時候對方就是風吹過來然後
你風打不動那種感覺
我要怎麼樣可以不反應我要怎麼樣
不是他這樣子我就這樣過去
從我本來會把浴缸打壞
到我現在可以冷靜的開車
這件事情有一個很重要的
部分剛剛丁姐的那個描述
其實就是我們所謂的後設
就是我後設往後看我
發生什麼事他發生什麼事
你看的不只是自己還有別人
然後還有一個很重要的部分
是其實丁姐可能已經是很
自動化做這件事所以
沒有感覺因為你剛剛有講一個步驟
那個步驟是大家最難
但是也許你已經習慣
你沒有發現就是其實你有讓你
自己停下來就是像你剛剛說
的一開始你可以維持幾分鐘
冷靜但是後來還是會跟
他吵那個過程就有點像
我讓自己停了下來我就
有辦法可以讓自己的前額葉
工作 但是有的時候火氣太大
我的那個讓自己停下來自我
安撫的能力還沒
那麼好的時候我還是會被拉過去
一旦我自我安撫的能力越來越好其實
就是轉念的能力能讓
自己停下來的能力
越來越好我比較可以有選擇
關於那個選擇是什麼我覺得還有
一件事就是說女生常常
都覺得說為什麼是覺得臺灣的
女性的議題會更多
我覺得還有一件事是因為我們
不太讓自己強壯
我們不太喜歡跟強壯連結
我覺得那個強壯
不是只有身體的強壯
有時候身體的訓練
它是會帶給你心更多的support
所以當你的
身體在某些能力是
有的例如說
你會跑得快然後你的反射
也能夠去保護你自己
我覺得這個 就很像你有存款
你會更有底氣
那種感覺就
很像是那個工藤新一跟小蘭
他絕對不會想跟小蘭打架
沒錯沒錯
我在 講這句話的時候
其實我腦部已經在思考了第一點
家裡有什麼東西
我是可以保護我自己
其實我腦筋已經在跑
如果真的發生什麼
事情的時候我可以快速讓我
自己到一個安全的狀態所以
我在講這件事情的時候我已經在
思考我後面的事情了
因為我知道我有足夠的能力
來保護我自己是所以我
為什麼一直鼓勵女性
一定要運動 我覺得你的運動不但是讓
你自己身體強壯我覺得你
心也會跟著越來越強
這也是為什麼就是丁姐這一本書
裡面有講到強調
身心靈不是只有心的訓練
還包含身體的訓練
不過我個人也真的是蠻認為
身體的訓練對我們有幫助
因為我以前是完全不運動的
我大概在疫情 開始之前
我真的是一個完全不運動 跑個不到100公尺
我就覺得我不行了  就是然後
疫情開始我開始發現因為
那時候剛好樂團有要巡迴
然後我就發現不行了
現在體力不是那麼好 所以就開始要
運動就後來就發現這個
運動的過程對我因為
包含就是說我心情不好的時候
我狀況不好的時候以前就會吃
東西然後不然就是喝東西現在
第一個反應就是去跑步
去跑走出去都好對
去走一走先去跑一跑
然後你會在那個過程
中你感覺到你跟自己相處的感覺
然後也會在
重訓的過程中每一次
感覺到自己在
挑戰自己極限一點點 然後那種自己的
我好努力對然後自我
效能感很強 因為會覺得
說我好棒哦 就是我知道我
可能做不到 但是我在努力沒錯
沒錯 所以我覺得這件事情是很棒的事情
所以我也非常的覺得丁姐裡面講到就是身心靈
必須要一起去一起工作是
一件非常重要的事情
那我最後想要請丁姐就是因為
今天的例子很棒真的很棒 然後
丁姐這個分享
實在太豐富 所以我還是希望可不可以
請丁姐回過頭來
幫我們介紹一下關於這本書
對不起
不會不會不會不會
因為這很好聽這真的很好聽
所以關 於這一本就是
丁寧的轉念學 丁姐想要帶給
我們什麼可以請丁姐介紹一下這本書嗎
我非常喜歡 我那天去看人類圖
我覺得人類圖講非常他講出
我現在正在做一件事
他說你有一個特質就是你可以
把無形的東西變成有形
這是你很特別的地方
我覺得這本書就是這樣因為我
會一直講說我上了那麼多的課程這些課程
看起來都很飄渺
都是在天上飛的 身心靈 哇
什麼腳可以離地什麼的 然後
我覺得身心靈是人在生命裡面
無論你有沒有意識到 像空氣一樣
他是存在的
但是如果你能夠好好的運用它
他就可以幫助你的生命和生活更有意思
然後他可以幫助你這個版本的升級
就像冰山 有7％在上面 我現在顯現出來的
下面有93%在下面 那我覺得
你要啟動下面這些%數 你就要開始
讓你的身心靈一起合作
那我練習了那個長我發現說
這些東西一定要落實在生活裡面
所以我自己又開始做很多練習
我覺得身體是一個很重要的媒介
身心靈太飄渺了 抓不到
但至少你可以藉由你這個身體
在執行的過程裡面 你才可以慢慢地了解
或是連結  身心靈裡面講到的東西
我希望身心靈的東西能夠落地
然後可以被應用在生活當中
作為可以幫助我們的東西
真的在你的生命裡面得到很好的效益
而不是說你花了很多錢  然後你覺得
誒？我好像只能跟
某些固定的人說某些固定的話
但日常生活沒有辦法實用
對對對 我覺得你連到菜市場都可以用得到
我每一天都有我們說的金句
就是說大家印象中有沒有彩虹卡啊
我們常在抽卡嘛
就把這東西當成抽卡
剛開始的時候你可以跟著我的步驟
因為三十天由淺到深 不同的練習
我們剛開始講剛剛咖啡的練習
後面有探照燈的練習
探照燈的練習就是把你的注意力
不斷地往外放 然後轉到自己
所以你要永遠帶著探照燈 看著自己
看著外面
然後我每天都一個金句 例如說
第三天就是撫觸可以鎮定神經
其實都是一個很簡單的道理
那就是自我安撫
你也可以安撫你的另外一半
或是你的 小孩
給他們多一點身體的碰觸 催產素
我們生命裡面就三件對我們最有影響
一個就是自己跟自己的關係
所以你也有你自己跟你自己關係的練習
例如說 早上起來躺在床上
摸摸自己 感覺自己身體
因為很多人是不感覺自己身體的
然後 與關係的練習 就是我們旁邊的人
伴侶啊 朋友啊  什麼的關係
今天可以試著多碰觸 或是擁抱家人
第三個就是與工作上的練習
今天在安全與尊重的範圍內
拍拍同事的肩膀 或是握手
然後我一定會加一個行動
因為我是非常重視action的人
你做完這些一定要去做一個行動
就是泡澡或按摩
還有同時寫些自己的努力
然後我都有會一些小小的叮嚀 行動小叮嚀
因為很多人會說 我不知道你在講什麼
安慰自己什麼的 然後我舉我的例子
然後怎麼去執行 可以讓他可以更具象化
對 我們都知道你要建立一個壞習慣很快
可能一個禮拜兩個禮拜就建立了
但是一個好的習慣要二十一天
也就是說建立一個好的習慣是比較困難的 所以我在把時間再拉長
把它建立三十天
你三十天完之後，你都可以繼續練習
你可以用什麼方式練習呢？
我覺得像抽牌  每天早上起來翻一頁
第十天講的 如果你不愛自己 你怎麼給別人他所需要的愛
那你就可以帶著這句話 進入你的一天
我在裡面有特別設計 就是呼吸法
因為呼吸是最快能夠鎮定神經的方法
因為他真的是一個
很多研究指出就是對自律神經平復的方法
所以我就瑜伽裡面常常用到的呼吸的方法
同時 除了文字下來之後，
我也有把它拍成影片
就是說你也可以上我的臉書
我在每個禮拜都會釋出一條影片
那你可以看 然後有一些靜坐簡單的引導
因為我也不是一個靜坐的老師
我自己也不是那麼坐得住
但是依我僅知道我對靜坐的感受
用一般人可以做到的方法 然後我們來做
但是如果你說第一點
你覺得你什麼都非常好
但是你覺得你相信自己的人生
可能有機會更好 升級 或是2.0
他是適合你的
又或是你常常覺得自己每天都沒什麼活力
我對很多事沒興趣
然後我常常覺得很沮喪 憂鬱
就是不開心的%比較高  他也非常適合你
我其實剛剛在聽就是丁姐講的時候
我最後補充一個這本書他會讓我想到什麼
我最近在看一個書 我忘記是哪一本
然後有一個心理學家就講到說
人到大概五十歲以上，
開始要跟你心裡的靈性做連結
這件事情其實很特別 ，
因為我自己畢竟原本我是念傳播
那後來我念諮商，
就是心理學相關，還是比較偏向
雖然社會科學其實離實證科學還是有一點點遙遠
因為有很多東西不一定完全可以證實
可是呢，它還是偏向科學的方式多一點
所以對我來說，
靈性這件事情其實是離我比較遙遠
然後我不會完全不碰，
但是我能碰的還是一個比較有架構跟系統
比如說像星盤這種，
它可能有一個架構跟系統
所以我反而會覺得說丁姐這本書，
因為這丁姐就是身心靈的很多的集結，
所以如果你對於你自己好奇，
有時候在談一些心理學的一些東西的時候
你會覺得有的東西難度比較高，
然後呢那個那個好像哦
好像聽起來很有道理，
可是我不太知道應用在生活裡
你想要有一個可以應用在生活裡跟
你的身心靈結合稍微近一點探索的部分
我會很推薦就是大家可以看看
就是丁姐的這本書
因為裡面包含丁姐怎麼從
就是原本的狀態，然後開始走轉念
然後開始跟自己的身心靈做連接，
一些小應用，小練習
然後我怎麼樣開始可以用在自己生活
我覺得這是一個非常非常實用
那可能在你平常自我安撫，
然後對自己身體不熟 情緒不熟
朋友是一個非常非常好的
暖身跟入門的一個方式
我也覺得說如果說你心情不好的時候，你就打開來翻看你會翻到什麼。
對，你可以想一下這句話帶給你的感受
那我其實我一直覺得說生心靈
其實也是非常科學的
只是說可能是我們講太多理論
但是今天有一個人他透過這個理論
去把它在生活上實踐看
他發現真的非常有用
所以我認為說身心靈
基本上就已經是跟我們生活在一起了
只是說我們一直找不到怎麼樣去
形容他或去操作他
就可能他沒有離我們生活這麼近
而在看這本書的時候發現
跟我現在學的東西有很多是很相近跟重疊
而且你每天都在遇到你的身心靈
沒錯沒錯，真的是這樣，
所以今天真的很感謝丁姐跟我們分享
就是丁姐的這本書
再跟大家分享一次，丁寧的轉念學
現在就是各大書店全部都買得到
那還有丁姐的FB,
歡迎大家可以上去就是追蹤
因為如果想要知道更多關於
怎麼樣跟自己的身體相處
可以問我，可以問我，我喜歡回答問題
然後也可以看影片，然後有很多練習
大家都可以跟著影片做，
那跟著影片做，因為感覺會更深，對不對
所以今天真的感謝丁姐，
謝謝大家，希望大家多多支持
那麼周慕姿放心說，
我們下次見，拜拜。